Good.
Ok. M c c a b.
My name's pauline mccabe
and i'm a natural pairs.
I work in nimbin in a small business
called the nimbin apothecary.
And i've been living in this
area for about five years now.
I first came up here about six
or seven years ago to visit friends who
had bought into a multiple occupancy up
here. And. I really love the area and.
Realised at the time
that i could buy a house
or land up here for much less money
than it would cost me in melbourne.
Which was definitely an attraction
but i suppose chiefly it was really the
natural beauty of this area that drew me
and still does.
Apart from the alternative culture.
With alternative medicine in nimbin
probably started at the aquarius festival i
think there were i wasn't there but
there were healing stalls and massaged
and all of that sort of thing
occurring at the time.
In 1973 and then amongst the
people who settled here following
that there were quite a number
of natural therapists and.
I suppose. One of the central
activities around which this.
Which became a sort of core. And magnet
for natural healing was birth and beyond.
You know about birth and beyond.
So birth and beyond
catering for pregnant women
and births at home were also very
much involved in natural therapies
and they actually taught themselves some
of them the midwives things like herbal
medicine and homoeopathy there were
a couple of trained acupuncturists
and they kind of set up a healing centre
in nimbin which revolved around the earth
and beyond and i think that
was the beginning of it.
And i don't know whether there was it at
the time 20 years ago a chiropractor in
lismore there might have
been but apart from that.
My understanding is that there was
no other sort of natural medicine.
And since that time i mean birth
and beyond. It's still going.
It's been a very successful case of
community development in health care
run by equally by train midwives
lay midwives and mothers.
And 14 years down the track.
It's still quite a viable
and vibrant organisation.
So simply with all the new settlers
that came to the area were a significant
number of natural therapists of all kinds
and it's become the whole area has become.
Very well known for all kinds of natural
medicine and that has spread from nimbin.
To lismore and all the
other surrounding towns.
Ripped through.
Well all the major mode elitism
represented which are chiropractic
and osteopathy homoeopathy.
Herbal medicine natural pathy
and traditional chinese medicine
which basically includes acupuncture
and chinese herbal medicine and apart
from that there are many other.
Lesser known sorts of theory p such as.
Polarity therapy reflexology all kinds of
alternative psychological therapies such
as. How. Rebirthing.
Gushed out child therapies.
In l.p. Just to name a few.
There are many many of them.
Well i think that. Healing is
an instinct that everybody has.
It's a very creative activity
and i think
that there's generally throughout society
a growing move to take responsibility
for one's own health and
a lot of the people
that get involved in healing start off by
healing their own illnesses be they minor
or major and through that they develop
an interest in natural medicine so
that.
Less and less these people go to doctors
and take drugs and resort to surgery
and they try all sorts of other
means and then they maybe go
and get some some training
and become qualified natural therapists
in some field that interests them.
Or maybe they don't. Maybe they
just. Can. Do you to practice.
As unqualified to parts in areas as a lesser
mode ality such as you know massaging
crystal syrup in things like that.
But basically i see it as a sort of.
Part of a wider social movement towards
taking responsibility for one's own health.
Taking it out of the hands of other people
and learning how to improve
your own health and be healthy.
Not waiting until you get sick and then
going to see a so-called expert who.
Attempts to manage your
situation with drugs
or surgery.
Fringe.
A lot of.
Times.
Well.
Basically i think there's growing acceptance
of natural therapies simply because
they work. That's why they won't go away
and and the ones that stick with us
and the ones
that are becoming gradually mainstream
such such as chiropractic which you now go
to university to learn and you become
qualified as a doctor of chiropractic.
That's happened because it's valid
and it works it's better than the
orthodox medical approach to lots of back
complaints and that's been
proven now by research.
And of course they've been ordered natural
therapies which haven't attracted much
interest haven't been particularly
successful and they have fallen away.
When i'm trying to think
of as an example where.
No i've lost can't think of that.
But the mainstream therapies no such
as herbal medicine and acupuncture
and homoeopathy have stayed with us.
And indeed growing because
they're effective
and even within the ranks of the medical
profession itself now we have a growing
numbers of young doctors who
are taking up these therapies.
And taking up the concept also of holistic
medicine which is to treat the whole
person to interact with the whole person
during the process of a of a therapeutic
consultation and.
Along with that has come the advent of the
multi-disciplinary clinic where you get.
Medical doctors working
alongside natural therapists
and psychologists for
example in a group practice
and referring clients to each other according
to what would be the most suitable
approach.
Those things.
I think industry near it's fairly unique
in terms of the world in australia
and we have developed. Well i'm a
natural power so that's the field
that i know the best
but we have developed a kind of synthesis
of various natural therapies which hasn't
occurred widely elsewhere in the world
in naturopathy study herbal medicine
homoeopathy nutrition
vytorin and mineral therapy
and so you have a combined approach
and it's very effective and.
Because of
that we have i mean there have been a
number of studies particularly in victoria
or inquiries i should say
government inquiries
and some research which
is proven that that.
The outcomes of natural therapies patients
are very happy with them natural passive
the least number of
complaints to the consumers.
Complaint department
and.
Drive them. You have
to get me going again.
Fringe elements we were
talking about places.
Apart from the the major mode allergies
which i've already talked about there are
lots of sort of other theories that kind
of on the fringe of natural need is
and such as crystal healing and rebirthing
in all of those sorts of things
that are abundant in this area.
I personally think that that healing is
a very sort of individual and creative
but in one aspect of it one
end of it's spectrum and
that out of the community at a grassroots
level periodically spring through some
individual a new theory p and
an example of that is they
and their p which was developed
by a man called tombo
and down in geelong who was just
a very intuitive body worker
and developed a sort of soft tissue
type of approach to all sorts of back
muscular and joint problems and
his approach is now being taught
and it's very successful.
So that's just an example and i think
that we we always have
to to remain open to.
The birth in a sense of the new
therapies. Into the world and.
Those that are not valid for
the way and those that.
Develop and grow
and eventually become a widely practiced
therapy i mean this was the case with
chiropractic for example in america.
Developed by a man called palmer
and he was not a trained
medical practitioner.
And i suppose over sounds of years
that all sorts of therapies have initially
begun with one individual who was
fascinated by healing and somehow
the vision came to them suddenly
or gradually of how to go about
developing a particular approach
and then other people learn it.
Ok.
You get a lot of different terms for
natural therapies such as complementary
medicine which is the term that's increasingly
being used for the six major modelo
ts also alternative medicine.
But that's becoming.
Kind of less popular because
it's sort of divisive.
Another term is holistic meters
and that's a particular term
that has been taken up within the
medical profession and nursing and.
There is certainly a growing group within
those orthodox professions a kind of
breakaway group which is developing
what they call holistic meds
and within their frame of reference holistic
medicine is the way you approach the
client of the kind of
interaction that you have
that instead of just the doctor sitting
across the desk from a patient who is just
a physical entity or a machine
made up of running parts
that the holistic doctor recognises
that he is talking to a person with.
Emotional spiritual and mental components
or energy fields you could say.
And so the holistic
practitioner not any doctors
but natural therapists as well.
Interacts with the client in
that way and sometimes when you
when you open up a consultation.
To include all those other
levels of being then.
It allows a safe place for for
for example for expression of.
Stress
and emotional difficulties which have
been contributing to physical disorders.
So that sometimes one doesn't
even need to prescribe anything.
And. Healing can.
At the very least be helped along on a
new energetic level by the person being
allowed to express the full spectrum of
these symptoms not just the physical ones
but all the other things that are a part
and parcel of the whole self.
Is extremely different because.
Holistic medicine is very different from
the traditional orthodox medical approach
because.
Orthodox medicine is based
on reductionist science and
that developed out of the
cartesian philosophy.
Of analysis we had by you only
believed what could absolutely
and irrefutably be proven and.
Within
that context with our science as it is
we have largely only been able to prove
things within the physical realm.
Particularly within medical science
physics as a whole different matter
and the new physics is
starting to affect us a whole.
It's society really and in different ways
but. That's a whole different matter.
So the traditional doctor only
dwelled on the physical because
that was the area only area which was in
which his medicine is proven can be proven
to have predictable effects.
And so he cannot ethically move
outside of that physical area.
He's bound by that. According to
the tenets of scientific medicine.
Of course you get individual doctors who
are real human beings with healing ability
who do move outside of
that room who spend time talking to people
particularly within the holistic medical
movement
but also there are other good doctors who
relate to people more widely now particularly
because people demand that
and shop around for doctors who
will treat them as people.
So it is extremely different
holistic medicine.
Yes. Ok.
The basis of all systems of medicine
really is shamanic medicine which is
right across the world in every continent
continent. They sickly similar.
And the shaman.
Is a sort of combination herbalist
and psychologist and priest
and. We all started off like that.
Thousands of years ago
and then in areas of civilization such
as greece china india more sophisticated
types of medicine came into being gradually
which. For example with her pocket is.
Approached healing through.
Diet herbal medicines climate exercise.
Those sorts of areas and that was
the western tradition of medicine.
For about 15.
You know 2000 years probably.
Until it was overturned
by the development of.
Science particularly with descartes
and his method of analysis.
So we have in the west and we we have a
history of conflict between orthodox
and unorthodox medicine which
didn't happen in india
and china in china they had five thousand
years of uninterrupted development of
their natural medicine and it's a very
sophisticated model in the western world.
We had. Will probably the conflict
started about around about the year.
Twelve hundred
when the first universities came into being
in medicine shifted into the study of
medicine shifted into the
university system and.
There was the elite medical system practiced
by those who were university trained
and their wealthy people who could patronise
them which was a minority of people
and other than that there was
just grassroots folk medicine.
And this situation went along for the
last eight hundred years with sort of
vilification of folk medicine
by university trained people
and you have to bear in mind that.
Scientific medicine only began about
three hundred years ago so prior to
that for hundreds of years we had
vilification of folk medicine because it was
practiced by unlearned and people who
didn't know anything about philosophy
or didn't speak latin didn't know
the theories of gaiman. Etc..
So it's interesting a sociologically that
there's been that split that hasn't.
Rested on science at all science with a
useful tool for them to rest upon to
further denigrate natural medicine.
But that's changing too gradually.
As.
Well in this area in.
Lismore because of the wide community
interest in natural medicine
and because we have a university
here which is fairly entrepreneurial
and interested in reflecting
community. Interests.
They have approved a three year
curriculum for a bachelor's degree in
that year obviously and also similar i
think in traditional chinese medicine.
So those courses are actually
approved but not yet funded and.
Funding could be some years away that
it's really a fascinating development
and if it.
If we get naturopathy into the university
here will be to my knowledge of first in
the western world.
And it will mean that for the first
time in eight hundred years.
The traditional medicine will move much
closer to a place of equality with.
A lead orthodox medicine and that is a.
A fascinating development
and. So much potential.
Possible.
Progress.
In australia.
I think nimbin is been very important in
the development of natural therapies in
this area.
I don't think
that it's been an impetus australia wide
because people who qualified natural
therapist in this area
have trained elsewhere
and there are very advanced centres of
natural medicine in melbourne sydney
and brisbane particularly.
But all of the training is private in
private colleges. You know that's not true.
There are now university courses in
acupuncture in melbourne and perth i think
and possibly sydney in chiropractic
in osteopathy in melbourne.
This is a course starting up in brisbane
taste college next year in homoeopathy
classical homoeopathy so it
certainly on the move in australia
and i think that's why we're getting a
backlash of legislation. Happening.
Particularly through the
therapeutic goods act
but nimbin is interesting because of the
numbers of people who practice in not only
neiman but the whole northern rivers ria.
It's a real sort of hotbed
of natural medicine and.
So it has the potential to
become a very important centre.
If we get the university course here.
Politics.
Because.
Isn't.
Will the politics of health a
really fascinating and very complex
but it's basically comes down to
a power struggle health care in.
This country is worth billions and it's a
vital component of our entire economy.
And if suddenly overnight all the people
who could benefit from most from natural
medicine was shifted out of
that system probably our economy would
collapse because of its cause that's a
hypothetical situation that
i just wanted to raise
that point to show you how
important it is to our economy
and consequently the control
of it is extremely important.
And and the fact is that in australia.
People are voting with their feet and
moving in their thousands every year.
Towards natural medicine the australian
natural service association estimates now
that there is something like 10 million
consultations with natural therapists in
australia per year and
that in fact this is actually saving our
country a lot of money in terms of the
health dollar. Because it's all paid
for out of the private pocket and.
It probably saves people surgery for example
it saves hospital days it gets people
back to work quicker.
And that's really all an unknown there
are sort of estimates made of what
that is really worth but
no good research on it.
So control of the health dollar.
Is a major issue and.
Because of the growing interest in
natural therapies in australia.
Even within the medical profession.
There's a backlash developing ever since
i've been involved in natural medicine in
the last 20 years we've had one attempt
after another two to repress natural
medicine
and i mean back in the 70s in victoria they
wanted to ban us along with scientologists
they put us into the same category.
And they've been numerous
inquiries and again in victory.
Area where there's been the most activity
there was one attempt to control.
Vardaman and and mineral syrupy
and put it more substantially into the
hands of the medical profession and
that provoked an enormous public
outcry they got more letters over
that issue than any other issue.
Politically and so
eventually they realised
that they weren't going to succeed by
trying to squash the therapists themselves
there was too much public support
and also with each inquiry
they got less biased
and actually more open more interested
in finding out what was really going on
and so.
The best one so far as been the victorian
social development committee an all party
inquiry and they actually did
some good research into.
Things like our standard of education.
Patient satisfaction reasons why people go
to natural therapies all those sorts of
things and it was a very
fair and worthwhile report.
And interestingly they came up with the.
Finding that we didn't need to be
registered because we do no harm.
And
that was a real disappointment to the natural
shape as we wanted to be realistic because
we needed the protection
of a registration system.
To protect us from orthodox medicine.
But the inquiry in victoria
didn't perceive that as.
They were looking into that.
So the tactics of shifted.
We've now got the therapeutic goods
department which used to be different in each
state and it because of that it was.
The rules and regulations
were different in each state
and it was a bit of a shame as all really
made interstate trade for example in
natural therapies in the
manufacture difficult.
Different labeling requirements
and all of that sort of thing.
So they decided to make it a federal
department based in canberra.
Which in lots of respects was a good idea.
And it meant that everything could be sort
of standardised from one central area
but having got the power
centralised in canberra.
They then commenced to.
Look at the contents of all
sorts of medicines and anything
that they could band on the sort of
slightest pretext for example come free
that if you age five bucketfuls of
country a day you would get ill.
Anything they can possibly
banned as being banned.
And it's an ongoing process
is not complete by any means.
And. The tenets that they're using.
The reasoning that they're
using to ban these medicines.
Is based on the chemistry of herbs
according to the reductionist model is
you break them down into component parts
you find out which parts are active
and which parts are not which only depends
on what they can prove in the laboratory
and if you find a particular ingredient
which is usually the alkaloids which may be
dangerous in large quantities
that justifies its banning. But.
Herbalists know that who works
because of the synthetic action by
that meaning the combined action
of all of its different parts.
In other words the whole is greater
than the sum of its parts.
And that when you put those
alkaloids back into the.
Context of the living plant with all
its components that there are checks
and balances within that.
Meters and that the total
plant. Has a healing.
Power which is not been researched.
They don't know why comfrey works or why.
Goldenseal works
or why most other whose works if there
has been some research now to show
that things do work for example st.
Mary's this or which is a
wonderful regenerator the liver.
But the complexities of how there is herbs
actually go about creating this healing
is not understood at all
so to ban them because
when you break them down into parts
and if you administered simply the alkaloids
in large quantities in a person would
get you to herbalist is a nonsense.
And we didn't we don't prescribe
comfrey by the bucketful and.
And herbs are also prescribed in
combinations with each other.
You really give one heard on its own.
So if you give her a mixed
with 8 herbs in it.
The complex of varying active ingredients
you know not only the alkaloids
but the essential oils the proteins
all sorts of complex ingredients.
The synergistic healing effect of
those can be perceived as an outcome
but how it works. We don't know.
So people medicine
and homoeopathy has fallen into the hands
of a group of canberra scientists who are
using their method to determine what we
are allowed to use and what we are not.
As they see it as untrained people you
see because we don't have registration
because we don't have university
education they consider
that we are not to be trusted
and the centuries of herbal tradition
which we learn is meaningless.
Within the context of their science.
And so we think it's very important for
us to keep fighting for university
education and.